you take the baton from the ones who've  come before and you carry it as far as  you can and then you end it off punch  away from Honolulu mostly grew up in  Indonesia for a while to you a whole  different type of brother you do realize  that right it's not my scene  what is your scene I'm still trying to  figure that out  surprise pop oh my word  you know I'm the only black person in  four of my five classes oh you're half  white too you can fit in anywhere fit in  no world is a big place you'll find your  way  you got some ID I'm a student here ID I  don't I don't see you I deem them so  what's so special at me huh  turning nothing  so how does change happen I believe in  the people creating chance  mouse mechana sin Maya that's from Kenya  and you know what that makes you  so I I don't it makes you American  love time death now these three things  connect every single human being on  earth we long for love